当然是用单词表
你找来一本单词书
左边一列是要学会的外语单词
右边一列是对应的中文翻译
你用手先蒙住左边
再蒙住右边
嘴里一边念念有词
据说如此
你的头脑便可以记住这些单词
但真的可以吗
多年前的某天我和老师打赌
要用一个月记住500个单词
再当着全班的面在黑板上听写
我有一个简单而强大的动机
让靠窗的那个女孩子注意到我
这个动机驱使我开始了夜以继日
每天四五个小时的苦背
背到后面
我甚至知道某个单词
在哪一夜的哪个位置
一个月后
我在听写表演中一战成名
也如愿在QQ上度过了
一个快乐的暑假
开学之后
老师想让我没开二度
再来一次听写表演
我满口答应
铺开了三个月不见的单词
指我充满信心的
指向第一个单词
不认识
我跟自己说没事
这一个当时背的就不熟
再下一个
不认识
我快速翻动着单词
指生怕目之所及
皆不认识
而事实正是如此
手指在500个单词上逐一划过
我的心脏绝望地跳动了
490多次
在震惊与困惑中
听写表演被仓皇取消
但同时也留下我的一个天问
为什么
为什么要学会一个外语单词如此困难
要回答这个问题
我们首先要回答一个更基本的问题
单词是什么
What is a word
想一下dog这个单词
认知心理学家
Steven Pinker说
The word dog
does not look like a dog
walk like a dog
or wolf like a dog
but it means dog
just the same
一个看起来
听起来偷不像狗的符号
却代表着狗的意思
这是因为每一个讲英语的人
在童年时都经历了相同的记忆过程
把dog这个任意的符号
或者说这个任意的名字
与狗这种动物联系在了一起
这便是语言学上著名的
所需而任意符号理论
Socius arbitrariness of the sign
单词是一种任意的符号
当我们使用单词的时候
我们再用一个约定俗成的名字
dog
代表某个特定的意思
人类最忠实的朋友
只不过对于英文使用者来说
这个约定俗称的名字是dog
对于日文使用者则是犬
对于我们则是狗
再进一步说
假设我们创造出这样一个新符号
然后约定明早起床之后
所有人都用它来指代狗
只要所有人都持续一致的这样做
那么这个随意的符号
便会成为一个新的单词
成为狗的新名字
就像莎士比亚借朱利耶之口说
What's in a name?
That which we call a rose by any other name
Would smell less sweet
所以我们说一门语言的单词
便是这门语言赋予世间万事的符号
或者说是给世间万物所取的名字
而外语学习者所面临的第一个
也是最大的挑战
便是要把上千个任意的名字
和他们所对应的意思给一一记住
这也叫做
词形和意义联系的知识
而这可不是一件容易的事情
正因为词语是一种名字
对大脑来说记住一个单词
和记住一个人的名字
或者一串随机的数字
几乎没有什么区别
Steven Pinker说这就像是
Having to memorize a new betting average
or treaty date or phone number
我们也可以说
这是词汇学习的第一个难题
任意符号难题
就像是尝试记住50个新同学的名字一样
每次你背单词背到第10个
就会忘记前7个
背到第50个
你会短暂的忘记人生的意义
心理学家们广泛认为
我们的短期记忆
Working memory
一次性只能抓下
7个单位左右的信息
维持20到30秒之后
这些记忆很快就会消散
Public enemy number one of language students
is forgetting
那么该如何攻克遗忘的难题呢
一个显而易见的答案是
You should fight for getting with repetition
初中的我还不知道
什么是爱宾浩斯遗忘曲线
也没有千百万次斩灯的软件
但我用了一种
更加原始的手段来重复记忆
打印纸
没错
就是网上流传甚广的
A4纸背单词法
但实际上这个方法并不是新东西
它的前身是
阿兴极速英语密集
十多年前天涯论坛上
一个听起来颇为神棍
但有其道理的帖子
这个方法大致如下
选一本单词书
高考四六级托福亚斯
在一边放上词表
在另一边放一张白纸
把第一个单词记忆三遍
比如说
Ultimate
终极的
然后随即选择纸上的某个位置
把单词抄上去
不写其他任何信息
只抄单词上去
Ultimate
终极的
对下一个单词
重复以上步骤
记忆三遍
比如说
Simplicity
简单
选择另一个随机的位置
把单词抄上去
Simplicity
简单
下一个
Sophisticated
复杂的
同样抄上去
接下来便是关键
你要立刻停止背心的单词
用手指把前三个单词
全部挨个点一遍
检查自己的记忆
还记得
Ultimate
终极的
Simplicity
简单
Sophisticated
复杂的
这个方法的核心要求便是每背三个单词就必须停下
把纸面上已经记过的单词全部点插一遍
就好像这些单词的头顶上都有一个遗忘倒计时
每一次你成功地从记忆中提取出单词的意思
你便可以重设这个倒计时
你便可以重设这个倒计时并且让记忆更长一点点
Ultimate
终极的
Simplicity
简单
Sophisticated
如此类推大约一个小时
你就可以在一张白纸上写下三五十个单词
如果你严格遵守每背三个全点一遍的要求
那么这些单词会平均被你复习数十遍
把白纸揣在口袋里
等车时地铁上睡觉之前
只要有一分钟时间就随时随地再点一遍
那么单词的记忆就可以逐渐被延长到一两天
一星期半个月
任何单词记忆工具
打印纸
Flashcards
以及智能的背单词App
以及记忆软件Anki
都可以帮你达到类似的效果
它们属于同一类语言学习方法
词条式学习
Definition Learning or Glossary Learning
利用一个单词表
通过大量重复
逐个记住另外一门语言中万事万物的名字
据说从人类开始学习外语以来
这就是最受欢迎的方法之一
因为它确实是有用的
实际上对于一个初学者而言
这或许是最有效率的方法之一
你或许没有想过的是
一个婴儿在学习母语词汇的时候
他同时要了解一个新的事物
比如玫瑰
并且记住这个事物的名字
玫瑰这个单词符号
而作为外语学习者
我们已经知道了什么是玫瑰
只需要记住
它在另一门语言中的一个新名字
这位语言学家Nagy称作
World Knowledge Advantage
常识优势
学习外语词汇的时候
因为我们已经拥有了对世界的常识
所以我们的学习负担
反而比母语者婴儿的更小
这也就是为什么只要保证大量重复
各种词条式学习的方法
理论上都可以给初学者
带来快速的词汇量增长
我便是在十几张打印纸的帮助之下
如此生辈下来了五百个人一符号
成为了年纪上的英语之星
但是这是一个巨大的但是
这是一颗很快陨落的星星
还记得几个月后
我发现自己书背的单词
全然望尽时的惊喜吗
我知道我并不是一个人
你或许也一样
经过一个与单词
毫无瓜葛的暑假之后
你在秋分时节回到学校翻开书本
然后发现举目望去都是绝望
我称这种现象为秋分失忆症
后来我才知道这样的结局
是一定会发生的
有两个原因
首先即便经过再多次的复习
这些单词头顶上的
遗忘倒计时
也还在继续滴搭走动
除非你不厌其烦地继续复习
倒计时归零
记忆也会一去不顾
就像十年之后
看到曾经天天相见的小学同学
他的名字
无论如何也无法浮现一样
然后是更重要的一个原因
就用翻译家
Lomkato的总结
词条是学习最大的弱点
就在意他只能把互部相干脱离语境的单词
塞进大门
我们学习中唯一的依靠
就是母语翻译
That is the only nail you hang your new position on
如果说记住一个单词
就像是要把它牢牢地挂在记忆的墙壁上
而你却只有母语翻译
这一颗脆弱的钉子
那么不管你挥动多少次锤子
你也只能得到摇摇欲坠
一碰就掉的记忆
这说明词条是学习
虽然是有用的方法
但它却不是一个足够的方法
如果你赶时间的话
我建议你跳过接下来的九分钟四十三秒
直接到第二部分
去看你究竟应该如何学会一个单词
但如果你足够好奇的话
让我先带你去看一下大海
有多么宽阔
你可能早就注意到过
很多单词的词意不止一个
或者说换了一个语境
单词的意思往往会发生改变
这被称作词汇的多译性
Polismy
我最喜欢的是心理语言学家
Frank Smith的这个例子
在这一个句子里面
by这个单词表达了五种不同的含义
有某人创作在某种情况下
在某个位置旁边
通过某种方式和在某个时刻之前
And by the way
这还只是by这个词语
常用词意的一部分
顺便说一句
多译性并不是某一门语言的特殊现象
考虑这句中文
我们可以以以往的历史作为借鉴
三个以
不光有微妙的意义区别
而且还串在了一起
所以Frank Smith评论到
All the common words of our language
have a multiplicity of meanings
With the most common words
Being the most ambiguous
翻开词典
你会立刻发现
一个单词越是常用
比如说
Table
Chair
Shoes
Sock
Dog
Field
File
Take
Look
Go
就有55种定义
原学家Fries的统计显示
英语中最常用的500个单词
每一个平均都有着28种不同的定义
倒不是说所有这些定义
全部都同等重要
但有一点可以肯定
你历尽艰难记住的
一个个单薄的词译
都只是汪洋里的一盆水
不相信吗
比如我早以为自己学会了Dog这个单词
直到我读到了
Beware of the dog
Dog ear
Dog tired
Hop dog
这个我知道
Top dog
Dirty dog
Going to the dogs
Putting on the dog
我才知道
自己好像没有完全学会Dog
这个单词
这是因为人类语言的一大特点
是约定俗成化
Conventionalization
在长久的使用中
人们会赋予单词
很多字面以外的意思
semantically opaque meanings
!
这些约定俗成的意义
同样也是任意的符号
和一个个的单词
没有什么区别
也需要你逐个记忆
平心而论
面对一个困惑的中文学习者
你要怎么解释
不准查百度
为什么是七上八下
而不是八上七下
或者五左六右
三前四后
还比如我以为
自己早就学会了
take这个单词
鞋带
或者拿取的意思嘛
直到我读到了
Take after my dad
Take apart the TV
Take down my address
Take on a friend
Take on my shoes
Plane takes off
Take to the streets
Take on a project
Take on the enemy
Here's my take on the problem
Take up tennis
Take up half of the room
Take over the opponent
Take away the lesson
Burger for take away
Take me
For an idiot
我才知道自己好像没有完全学会
Take这个单词
这是因为英语中还存在大量的
Multi word combination
多词组合语
也就是英语老师耳听面命的固定搭配
语言学家Erman和Oren估计
超过一半的书面英语和英语口语
都是由这种组合语构成的
很不幸的是
多数时候我们无法通过短语里面的单词
推断整体的含义
所以这些短语也是任意的符号
也需要你诸葛进行记忆
因此
你认为的英语常用500词
是500行简单直白的词条
只需要诸葛记忆打勾即可
实际上的英语常用500词
可能有数以千计的词性意义习语
这便是单词的宽度难题
The width problem
单词的知识不是一条窄河
而是一汪海洋
在多亿汪洋面前
逐个背单词的过程
就如同是用一个小小的木桶
试图咬干词汇的海洋
如果你已经在哀叹
不想学英语了
先不要着急
因为更糟糕的是
我们还有第三个难题
单词的知识不是一滩潜水
而是一汪海洋
而大海深不可挫
在李光耀华语学习心得中
新加坡国父提到过
他三十多岁开始学中文的时候
往往会用错词语
比如会混用两个近似的词语
对付与应付
或者用错成语
类似的
在历尽艰难记住了五百个单词之后
初中的我面临的下一个难题便是
怎么用
答案当然是乱用
因为不要骗我
你肯定也干过这样的事情
去网上查几个高级英语单词
比如说very的高级词是
exceedingly
angry的高级词是enraged
bad的高级词是monstress
等等等等
然后在搞明白
他们为何高级之前
你就像孔雀开瓶一样
把作文里所有的
very angry bad
都给一键替换成
exceedingly enraged monstrous
这样一来
好喝的一句
I'm very angry about the bad weather
天气糟糕真生气
就变成了m exceedingly enraged
about the monstrous weather
这天气实在是骇人今世
我已然出离愤慨了
除非你是在描述重庆的夏天
或者成都的冬天
唯一骇人今世的
只有你的vocabulary misuse
用词不当
李光耀认为
这是词典编撰者们的责任
他们应该在字或词组
后面加上阔弧
来注明是贬义的
还是褒义的
我想这当然会有所帮助
但若要充分地反映
单词之间的细微差别
一个编撰者可能需要列表
说明sad的28个敬意词
比如bitter
dismal
melancholy
wornful
sumber
sorrowful
sorry
unhappy
and so on
有何区别
颇像是要区分
28种不同的蓝色
再者
不要忘记很多单词
在约定俗成化的过程中
逐渐改变了意思
而词典可能没有来得及
收录这种变化
比如我的现代汉语词典里面
写明
极品
只是我里面最优等的
比如说极品
美酒
那么我当然不能责怪
我苦学中文的日本朋友
俊
造出这样的句子
我的朋友
罗霄尼
真是一个极品
类似的我的日语
スーパ代季林词典里面说
きさま
在定义上是
目上の人に対して
尊敬の意を含めて
持ちる
那么俊也不能责怪
我对他说出这样的句子
きさまを心から尊敬しています
我打心底里尊敬您这位傻
不光如此再考虑一下
quite
很相当完全这个单词
语言学家
Kane Highland
为这个常见的单词
写了一整篇论文
他指出
在不同的情境下
这个单词
可以表达出相反的意思
比如说
It is quite an easy method
to complete the task
这种工作方式
真是太简便了
在这句话里面
quite的功能
是加强语气
strengthening的
不光是简便
而且是非常简便
简便的程度特别高
然而在
I don't quite follow you
我没太听明白你说的
这个否定句中
quite的意思
确实用来弱化语气
weakening的
不但没有搞明白
而且基本一点也不明白
明白的程度特别低
更让人糊涂的是
quite这个词
还可能根据语气的不同
而改变语义
This is quite a good idea
这确实是个好主意
但我不打算采用
This is quite a good idea
这确实是个好主意
而且我可能会试试看
也就是出
参与这个实验的香港大学生
基本上都对quite这个词的
微妙特性
没有充分的掌握
实际上
quite这个词的
准确定义和用法
在语言学家之前
都没有完全一致的意见
所以highland总结到
quite意义的复杂性
可能意味着教材习题
和语法教学
都无法完全让学生
准确掌握这个单词
以上种种都展现了
词汇学习的第三个挑战
单词的深度难题
the depth problem
也极准确使用一个单词的能力
你以为的单词知识
只是一滩浅水
一个词条两行
定义几个例句
实际上的单词知识
却是一口深不见底的井水
包括这个单词的词形变化
句法规则
搭配可能适用
常和词意特征
等等等等
a word in a word
is complicated
每一个小小的单词
所蕴含的知识
都比我们想象的更加宽广
也比我们想象的更加深厚
这就是为什么任何人
如果宣称
可以让你几天之内
学会数千上万个单词
不论是通过记忆术
还是构词的逻辑
等等说词
他们都在试图创造
生理学的奇迹
科学家们尚未在地球的任何角落
发现这样的奇迹
除了B站知识去
综上所述
原学家Nagy评论到
a dictionary
is not designed
to be a standalone
source of meanings
for words that are isolated
from a comprehensible context
therefore we must abandon
the belief
in contextless
vocabulary building programs
in which students
trying to memorize
the definitions
of lists
of unrelated words
and if that is the only
thing you've ever done
to learn vocabulary
you're trying to dig
an ocean
with a shovel
made of dirt
in other words
you're fighting a war
that is destined
for loss
那我还有救吗
yes
absolutely
还记得李光耀先生
勿用岂有词礼的故事吗
让我告诉你
我是怎样学会这个成语的
小时候有一次
我爸爸宣布政策
缩短了我的游戏
我立刻抗议到
其有词炼
我爸爸惊讶地问我
李从而收回了一个成语的
我反问到
撒子是成语
但暗藏在我的老夫子漫画里面
小小妮经常看到老夫子
一头撞在墙上
被重物压在地上
被别人拿来开玩笑的时候
他就会愤愤地来上一句
其有词礼
人类天然的模仿能力
让我记住了
只要被高的龟火毛的时候
都应该用其有词礼
回头一想
词汇学习的终极方法
似乎就在这个故事之中
而这个终极方法的名字
叫做context
context这个单词来源于
拉丁语的contextus
它的本意是编织在一起的材料
也表示的weaving together
of words in language
这是一个绝妙的定义
因为就像翻译家
Lomkato所说
语言文本永远都像是一件纺织品
一个从文本中剥离出来的单词或者短语
只能代表整体的一小部分
就像是一块布料
只能代表它所属衣物的一小部分一样
更关键的是
the threads interweave and strengthen each other
and this is how they give the whole
its color, form and stability
换言之
一个单词只有在文本语境之中
才会拥有完整的秘密
也只有编织在一起的词语
才会给文本带来生命和色彩
我们几分钟前背的三个单词
ultimate, simplicity, sophisticated
你应该差不多忘掉了
现在让我们把它们编织在一起
simplicity is the ultimate sophistication
终极的复杂就是简单
也就是大道质简的意思
你可能仍然没有牢牢记住它们
但是从此刻开始
这几个单词将会编织在一个语境下
存在于你的头脑中
所以我们说
words cannot be removed from their contexts
one can only understand them
and should only learn them in their contexts
这种学习方式被称作语境式学习
contextual learning
和逐个硬背单词的词条式学习不同
这种方法的重点在于充分理解
我们所读到或者听到的信息
可理解输入comprehensible input
并通过语境的力量学会词语
就我所知
contextual learning可以帮你破解前文
所述三个词汇学习的难题
the arbitrary sign problem
the width problem
and the depth problem
Let me explain
首先
语境可以帮你记住任意的符号
如果我给你以及你的朋友
分别看这样一张照片
但是我告诉你
这位男士是Baker 烘焙师
而告诉你的朋友
这位男士是Baker 贝克
几天之后让你们回忆
有关这张照片的任何信息
你的朋友可能要颇费脑力
才能记起来
Baker the Mr.
贝克先生
而你则可以轻易地回想起
Baker the profession
烘焙师
这就是心理学上著名的
The Baker Baker Paradox
尽管你和你的朋友
看到了一样的照片
听到了一样的话
但小写的Baker
却会比大写的Baker
留下更深刻的记忆
这是因为小写的Baker
在你的大脑中
有很多的联系
它会让你想起
白色的厨师帽
听到烤盘的碰撞声
闻到喷香的面包味
视觉听觉
嗅觉味觉
经历就像一个个钉子
或者传毛
又像交织在一起的丝线
把Baker
给固定在你的记忆中
这就是为什么
脑神经科学家
Lisa Genova认为
context
是人类记忆
任何事物的主要途径
Your brain captures
and binds together
The contextual details
surrounding what you experienced
Where you were
Who you were with
When this happened
How you felt about it
And so on
你最深刻的记忆
多半也都有着
各式各样的记忆线索
Gryffindor
格兰芬多
是不是立刻让你想起
一只狮子
或者温暖的
红黄色调的公共休息室
Welcome to the Gryffindor Commonly
银色的宝剑
Gryffindor
吃妹王良
是不是怎么
他就这么多
但是都吃了老孙的那一棒
每次放弃背单词的时候
abandon
是不是你唯一记住的单词
但那也是因为
他对你一次次的无情嘲笑
而大写的Baker
有什么记忆联系呢
基本上没有
就像是你硬背的那些
脱离语境的单词一样
除非你想办法
给他们加上语境的线索
Google Image
就可以帮你做到这一点
把你新学的单词
输进Google或者Beam的图片
搜索影群
Voila
用你自己的眼睛看看
Violet有多紫
Teal有多青
阳光下的湖泊有多么shimmering
发怒的猛兽有多么ferocious
当然最有效的一种
contextual learning
是直接去经历这个单词
比如在玩了几百个小时的
塞尔达传说之后
我这辈子可能都不会忘记
Nifaの祈り
いつでも使えるよ
Darukeの守り
いつでも使えるぜ
Libberのトロネード
いつでもOK
Olobosaの怒り
いつでも払ってるよ
这几句话里的
任何一个单词
但故事还没有结束
我们还有更麻烦的宽度和深度难题
难道说在语境中学习单词
也能帮我们学到单词的多种意义
以及单词的准确用法吗
Yes
And no
在某些情况下
语境中的一次相遇
就足以让我们学到完整的单词知识
比如说1985年
一项里程碑式的研究中
伊利诺伊大学的语言学家们
让一群初中生读了两篇文章
然后对他们进行测试
结果显示
所有学生都获得了显著而稳定的词汇知识
有10%左右的生词
只经过了一次相遇
就直接达到了完整知识的等级
例如其中一篇文章
是一个与间谍有关的故事
在主人公Fowler的想象中
特工们潇洒神秘操弄枪支
还应该像007一样
与美丽的帮女郎为伍
然而他跟踪了一位真正的间谍
Sable
但发现对方却是肥头大耳
住一间阴暗破烂的酒店房间
于是乎主人公感到了
Dissillusioned
结合语境
一部分学生立刻就可以准确地描述
Dissillusioned这个单词的意思是
If you have ideas about something
And you find out it's the opposite
You're disillusioned
Your beliefs are shattered
但是这种学习效果的前提是
这文章你得是大概读得懂的
你或许不认识Dissillusioned
但是如果你熟悉前文中的
Fail to let down
Disappointed
Frustrated
并且知道主人公经历了
想象和现实之间的落差
你有很大的概率可以推测出
Dissillusioned和强烈的失望情绪有关系
这就像是一幅拼图
如果绝大部分的拼块已经组好了
那么空缺的一两块并不会阻止你理解整个拼图
并且你还可以借助已有的
推测出缺少的
是什么
如果你的词汇水平是I
而你可以找到比自己的水平高一点点I加1的文本
那么你就能在可理解的语境中学会那部分加1的生词
这便是语言学上著名的可理解输入假说
Comprehensible Input Hypothesis
二语席的研究泰斗
Steven Krashen教授的主要理论
作为补充
语言学家Paul Nation认为
在98%的词汇覆盖率下
我们就可以基本不查词典
便读懂外语的文本
这意味着每读50个词遇到一个生词
或者一页书上有300个词
其中的生词数量大约在6到7个或者更少
如果这个数字下降到了95%
一页三百词的小说上面有十多个生词
那么你得时常借助词典
或者经常略过一些读不懂的地方
如果这个数字远低于95%
你不是在阅读
而是在破译密码
Forget about it
而即便你找到了自己的可理解输入
你的词汇学习仍然不是一蹴而就的
因为在语言学家Bekker Law的研究中
尽管61%的语境具有明确的指示性
但有31%的语境帮助有限
还有那么8%的语境是有误导性的
比如我的一位北京朋友Mia说
她曾经从一位嫁给上海人的东北朋友那里
学来了一个非常动听的上海话词汇
他们经常用温柔的语气相互使用这个词语
直到有一天Mia面对着她的上海客户
用出来了这个词语
然后发现好像和她理解的有点偏差
我问她这究竟是个什么词语
她说是策纳
这说明我们需要在多次变化的语境中与单词相遇
从而逐渐校准他们的意义和用法
实际上即便是婴儿在学习常用的母语单词
比如说Poor和Fail的时候
他们也普遍需要好几年的时间
直到童年的中期才充分掌握这些单词
这说明学单词是一个缓慢的渐进的过程
单词的知识并非只有dichotomy
并不只有学会了和没学会的二元状态
而是incremental持续递增的
单词学习并不是一个打勾框框
而是一个很长很长的进度条
你与单词的每一次变化相遇
都会让进度条往前推进那么一点点
你问我要重复多少次
好问题
要看情况
我相信聪明的你和我一样
有着天然的能力
可以只听见一两次
便学会各种语言中的脏话
英语里的fuck
法语里的put
粤语里的long
日语里的buck
四川话里的麻
上海话里的小嘴
等等等等
因为这些词汇有着最明确的语境线索
最浓郁的感情色彩
但其他几乎所有高频多艺固定搭配丰富
宽度越宽的单词
都需要你不厌其烦的在变化的语境中
和它们重复相遇
Nation的综述给了一个粗略的数字
要想充分地学会大部分单词
你需要在自然变化的语境中
重复遇到一个单词
至少12次
至此
关于如何永远学会一个单词
我们得到了下面的公式
找到词汇覆盖率98%
18左右的可理解文本
读100个词
大约2到3个左右的生词
并在变化的语境中
重复遇见生词至少12次
那么
要怎么做到呢
这是Dr.Lom Kato
前文中引用过的匈牙利翻译家
世界上最早的同声传译员之一
或许也是历史上最伟大的多语者之一
在他出版于1970年的著作
How I Learn Languages中
Lom Kato介绍到
I only have one mother tone
Hungarian
Russian,English,French,Anderman
Live inside me simultaneously with Hungarian
Translating texts
In Italian,Spanish,Japanese,Chinese,And Polish
Generally requires me to spend about half a day
Bushing up on my language skills
The other six languages
Bulgarian,Danish,Latin,Romanian,Czech,Ukrainian
I know only through translating literature
And technical material
I上十六门语言
是Lom Kato说自己用来赚过钱的
人们可能会说
这样惊人的语言能力
一定是因为
Lom Kato从童年开始
就经营在各种语言环境中的缘故
但事实是
Ien 学习的语言
Ien 学习语言
40年代学俄语
Lom Kato 为了躲避战火
在防空洞里
阅读俄国作家
果歌里的死魂灵
并且此时
因为二战尚未结束
他不敢大肆张扬地
查阅俄语词典
所以他
worked out her technique
of boldly skipping over unfamiliar words
其后学习中文
杰克语、西班牙语
读弦书都是他的秘密武器
他读懂的第一句中文是
全世界的无产者们联合起来
当然阅读不是他唯一的方法
因为让我先告诉你
阅读不能做到什么
Besides its million assets
Reading is only culpable in one thing
It cannot speak
Books alas cannot teach you exact pronunciation
想要学会语音语调
你要设法学会音标
你要花很多时间听这门语言
甚至还用monologue
自言自语来进行练习
在这一点上
仅仅阅读是不够的
阅读还需要很多时间
它无法让你两三个月
就在一门考试中斩获高分
相比于网络上一些高手
所声称的
几天让你记住一万个单词
这一点阅读也做不到
但是有一件最重要的事情
阅读一定可以做到
It is only books that provide an unlimited amount of repetition
It is only reading that can be returned to again and again
without being an audio
换言之
无限重复的要求
只有阅读可以帮你达成
如果你不相信的话
我帮你算过
2014年的一个夏日
刚刚高中毕业的我坐在一列长途火车上
对着一本二手小说目不转睛
在十多个小时的车程中
我听不见引擎的喧哗
也没有注意到窗外逐渐变暗的幻景
因为我的思绪全部集中在年轻美丽的Tracy Whitney身上
看着她受黑帮迫害
失去事业和子女遭受牢狱之灾
而后又跟随着她浴血重生
踏上复仇之旅
这是美国小说家Sydney Sheldon的If Tomorrow Comes
一年时间内
我在这位故事大师的十本小说中
见证了一位又一位勇敢女性的传奇生命
读到酣畅淋漓处
我经常猛然发现自己地铁坐过了三站
或者教室已经空无一人
除了阅读的喜悦
这十本篇幅总计一百零三万词的小说
成为了我英语词汇学习上最重要的敲门砖
我要再说一遍
阅读不是你外语学习的万能妙药
如果任何人宣称可以用一个方法
解决你所有的问题
那么只有一件事情可以肯定
他想要赚你的钱
所以我不会声称单纯读小说
就可以帮你顺利通过高考四六级托夫雅思
但是我们要来研究一个更加具体的问题
假如一个人可以读完十本
Sydney Sheldon或者同等水平的小说
他能不能预见大学英语六级考纲要求的大部分单词
并且平均预见十二次以上
首先我们将大学英语六级官方词表进行处理备用
然后利用语言学统计软件
Antword Profiler和Paul Nation的研究方法
我们可以统计出十本小说所有单词的出现频率
以及他们对六级考纲单词的覆盖情况
结论是
more than enough
六级词表所要求的5000多个核心单词中
十本小说里出现了4633个覆盖率超过90%
六级核心单词在十本小说里平均出现的次数
是26.2次远远超过了12次的最低要求
在这十本小说中有一些单词有着惊人的出现频率
例如 conceal隐藏这个词语出现了69次
你或许知道 conceal可以用来隐藏实体物件
比如说 conceal himself
wearing a veil to conceal her face
或许还知道可以用来隐藏事件
比如说 conceal the drama
conceal his crime
那么你是否知道它可以用来
conceal his shock astonishment
emotions
excitement
surprise
relief
hope
reaction
disappointment
real feelings
enthusiasm
and smugness
看到这里
你还会疑惑宽度问题是如何被解决的吗
但还没完
assure这个词出现了整整196次
几乎重进了这个参词所有可能的形式
assure
assures
assured
assurance
assurances
reassured
reassuring
reassuringly
reassurance
self-assured
self-assurance
看到这里
你还会疑惑深度问题是如何被解决的吗
and this is why we say you can learn everything about a word in reading
you can learn about its spelling, forms, common meaning, less common meaning and usage
你问我还有其他的单词也会这么重复吗
好像还有几个
比如attorney whisper damn
naked puzzle fuck
eager patient tremble
lieutenant shrug bitch
handsome expert upstairs
顺便说一句
欢迎到中国教育考试网上查找全国大学英语四六级考试大纲
打开文件你分别可以在第28页找到这个单词
以及在第65页找到这个单词
我们继续
还有
Talent Pilot Lobby
Cave Harbor Escort
Nightmare Headquarters Apology
Made Explore Sympathy
Sweet Fist Reveal
Discreet Air Triumph
Eldrage Soak Charity
Elaborate Gossip Emerge
Meticulous Turmoil Flourish
And Ultimate Bystander Ascend
语境线和无限重复
让阅读书籍成为了无可比拟的词汇学习工具
实际上我们似乎天生就懂得利用这种学习工具
语言学家们发现几乎任何一个学生都可以在没有什么指导的情况下
从故事漫画小说中习得大量词汇的意义
像林语堂所说
试问诸位少使看红楼水浒
何尝有人教何尝翻字典
你们的侄儿兽被现在看红楼西乡又何尝需要你们去教
近四十年应用语言学研究的共识之一
就是这种自发的消遣阅读很可能是一个人大部分词汇量的来源
不论是母语还是外语
即便没有这些语言学的证据
这也是一个简单的问题
这是一把大米
大约七八十克
总共三四千粒
而让我告诉你
你认识的汉字总数至少是这一把大米的例数
通用规范汉字表的一级字表有三千五百个汉字
一个初中毕业生的识字量
而这些汉字组成的常用二三四字词语的总数
可以达到六七万个
相当于两斤多大米的例数
可以煮出六七碗米饭那么多
类似的一个普通英美高中生认得至少两万个核心单词
以及他们的至少四万种衍生形式
这还不包括上万个人名地名物件缩写等等专有名词
现在让我问你
这样庞大的词汇量中有多少是你一个个翻词典学来的
答案一定是很少的一部分
否则从一岁生日开始
你醒着的时候每两三个小时就要翻一次词典
往这个杯子里面加上一颗米
才能在十八岁生日的时候
获得你现在的词汇量
那又有多少是老师一个个教会你的呢
答案仍然是很少的一部分
语言学家们估计最有效率的学校
一年也就能教三四百个单词
而且是他们最浅显的知识
相比之下掌握一门语言
需要成千上万的词汇
这种海洋一般的知识
要从哪里来
唯一的来源只可能是
这就像是阿西莫夫所说
我坚信自我教育是唯一的一种教育
学校教育会停止
而自我教育永不停止
词汇的学习或许就是自我教育最极致的体现
如果学校老师只能教你区区几百单词
那么没有人可以帮你把剩下的几千单词灌注到大脑中
只有你自己在海量的可理解输入中
在一生的阅读重复中
才能永远学会它们
但试问哪一门学问又不是这样的
哪一种学习就是老师可以带学生包办完成的呢
从数学到语言
从钢琴到舞蹈
从象棋到烹饪
获取任何一种知识的漫漫征途都只能靠你自己走完
如果说词汇的知识是一片汪洋
宽不见边 深不见底
那么里面的海水只可能来源于中年不断的雨水
而这雨水便是阅读
所以下一个问题便是
这雨水要从何处而来
答案当然是
答案当然是它要来自于一百万颗雨滴
所以请允许我向你介绍百万词阅读挑战
One Million Word Reading Challenge
首先回头去看我2020年做的第一个视频
快他妈三年了
以及到我的主页去找专栏的按钮
那里有一份从入门到进阶的书单
你应该可以在里面找到你的可理解挨家一输入
每读100个词大约2-3个左右的生词
你需要每天阅读30分钟
一周读5天
一年读40周
一整年下来
你就可以读完接近100万词篇幅的小说
相当于10本Sydney Sheldon
或者把Magic Treehouse系列反复读上两遍
你可以偶尔查阅词典
可以把遇到的生词写下来
也可以纯粹享受阅读
让单词们自己与你重复相见
你便可以在变化的语境中
重复遇到数千个生词
平均遇见数十次
从而知晓丰富的多译解决词汇的宽度难题
以及学会地道的用法解决词汇的深度难题
然后
不出意外的话
你应该会失败
别开玩笑了
总共100万词的书
多吓人的目标啊
很有可能你适用于以下两种情况
第一
你的词汇量
连阅读Dr. Seuss's ABC
这样的幼儿读物都寸步难行
第二
你想要跳过低诱的读物
直接挑战有趣的
但远超自己水平的小说
我都可以理解
Dr. Lam Cato曾经说
在语言学习中不耐烦
是一种健康的心态
那么你当然可以先背单词
然后阅读呀
英语中最常用的3000个核心单词
组成了85%以上的口语和书面文本
先记住他们的浅显意义
可以极大的降低你阅读的词汇负担
所以你当然可以先用第一章里
每背三个全点一遍
随时随地再点一遍的背单词方法
来先苦后填
背单词之后
立刻选择对应难度的阅读材料
比如说背四六级词汇
就读四六级的阅读
甚至背某本小说的单词
然后读这本小说
背完几百一千单词之后
再来阅读
你或许会得到一种天书顿悟的体验
曾经看不懂的文本
将会处处镶嵌着你才记住的滚烫的单词
就像把缺失的拼图完成一样
文字的意义将在你的面前豁然开朗
而对文本的理解
反过来又会极大的加深你所有的词汇知识
这说明你完全可以在阅读之前之中
和之后用词条式学习来辅佐
因为阅读不是万等的
任何小说里都会存在
只重复一两次的单词
也被称为one timers和two timers
你要么扩大阅读量
来继续和它们重逢
要么当然也可以记笔记查词典
甚至做一个阅读中遇到的单词列表
然后用软件来加强记忆
发挥自己的创造力
好吗
同时如果说Duck Lam Cotto
在90年前学外语的时候
头疼于无处学习发音
今天的你
有互联网上无数的视频和有声书
甚至你在B站上
就可以搜索到
母语者朗读的全套Magic Treehouse
你唯一没有的是找不到材料的借口
其次
刚才的计算是每天要读半小时的书
多吓人的目标啊
假设今天你受到我的鼓舞
找来书籍读了半个小时
明天你可能会坚持读十分钟
从后天开始你会荒废一个月的时间
然后某天因为愧疚打开书本想要再次尝试
但最终会在怀疑中自我放弃
直到下一次重打积雪
这是你会说
百万词阅读计划就是一个海市蜃楼
这是因为我们往往高估自己一两天内可以做到的事情
但低估自己一两年内可以做到的事情
所以在书类的重打积
我们在书类的重打积
与其从每天读半小时开始
我建议你从每天读一分钟开始
你没听错
比如每天吃完晚饭
在椅子上坐定之后
立刻拿起你选好的小说
然后只读一个自然段
借用斯坦福行为科学家B.J. Fogg的比喻
养成习惯如同是波洒一颗种子
你需要把习惯设计的特别特别小
小到一两分钟就可以做到
并且每天都可以做到
换言之
没有什么比让习惯活下来更重要
这就是我自己的故事
我挣扎了一年时间想要养成写作的习惯
一天写一千字
发现自己根本做不到之后
I ambitiously scaled down
一周写一千字
一天只用写一百来字一个自然段
甚至只写一句话
但无论多小
我都不能让习惯死掉
所以
让我们把百万词阅读挑战
改成半夜纸阅读挑战
你每天只有一个目标
阅读半夜纸的小说
只要读完这半夜纸
你的一天便可以宣告胜利
如果你还想继续下去
那当然没问题
但是你最低的要求就是
每一天都阅读半夜纸
在习惯活下来之后
再从半夜增加到一夜
增加到五夜十夜
从一分钟增加到五分钟
十分钟半小时
就像种子生根之后
再慢慢发芽成长
如果说你想知道
有没有榜样
已经帮你走过了这条路
这里有一位观众
在去年留下的评论
他说自己阅读了
44本Magic Treehouse
和五本纳尼亚传奇
采用的方式是
隔一个生词查一个
不用刻意去记
然后在词汇量测试中
在词汇量测试中
获得了至少三倍的数量增长
这只是几年来
我收到的许多类似反馈中的一条
但是它有意思的地方在于
这位朋友的阅读总量
估计至少五十万词
与他的词汇量增长
从印两千到三四千单词
和Paul Nation 2014年论文中的
估算非常吻合
但是有两个警告
第一
不同的词汇量测试
可能得出大相径庭的结果
而我不知道
这位朋友用的是哪个测试
此外
同样进行五十万词的阅读
一个初学者或许可以学会
两三千的词汇
但是一个中阶学习者
则只能学会几百个
原因很简单
初学者可以遇到更多的生词
这在语言学上称作Hips Law
或者Herdin's Law
此处不作展开
但是如果你接受半夜止的阅读挑战
请到基于Nation教授研究的网站
my.vocabularySize.com进行测试
记录你的词汇量变化过程
你读了
听了什么书
读了多少个词
挑战之前和之后
你的词汇量有何变化
然后发给我
或许这将是一个非正式的研究项目
到目前为止
我们讨论了很多词汇和阅读的研究
但是我们还有一件事情要说
不要听大人的话
前段时间我收到了一封邮件
里面有这样一张照片
这些Sidney Sheldon的小说属于一位粉丝
在邮件里面他并没有做任何的说明
但是我非常清楚发生了些什么
See for yourself
这是我自己的Sidney Sheldon小说
看到书籍上的折痕了吗
这里还有几本
还有一些我喜欢的nonfiction
他们的书籍上都有类似的折痕
我管这种折痕叫做书的咒文
让我告诉你它是怎么产生的
回想一下上一次你读的某本喜爱的小说
回想一下读到精彩绝伦处
那种被文字的力量卷入另一个世界
而忘记自我和时间存在的体验
对我而言这或许是哈利第一次走进对角巷
Wishing he had about eight more eyes
to see the cauldrons
Dragon lovers
Owls
Broomsticks
Quels
Rose of parchment
Potion bottles
Globes of the moon
或许是两个美猴王各踏云光
跳斗上九香云内不分真假一般挠打
又或许是罗吉面对着东方的晨光
用不高的声音说道
我对三体世界说话
每到此时
你会无意识地把书攥紧
就好像这是一个把手
抓紧它就不会掉回现实
而这个动作会给书留下一道道皱纹
你还会时不时翻回这些篇章
重新回到这些世界
所以书上的皱纹会越来越深
我有一个五段的结论
只有给书留下皱纹的阅读
才是真正的阅读
我们一直听说读书是为了考学
考学是为了前途
这些都是很好的理由
但是就没有其他的理由了
比如好玩怎么样
好玩怎么样
去图书馆的漫画或小说专区
翻开丁丁历险记
东方快车谋上案三国演义
你会看到封底上密密麻麻的借阅记录
被翻到发挥的纸张一道道深深的折子
你还会看到那些在阅读乐园中的孩子们
看到他们明亮的眼睛
但是后来大人们带来教材和习题
告诉我们年少莫读贤书
然后让我们的乐园关门歇夜
我们中的许多人再未体验过
阅读本应有的快乐
我们的眼睛也逐渐变得暗淡无光
殊不知读贤书才是获取知识和语言的梯子
我们应该读书
因为是书类的那些最有趣的方法
是一种理解的识论
而是一种根据的真实的真实的真实
是一种真实的真实的真实的
年少偏读贤书
2022年的一个春日
居家隔离的我在自己小小的仪式户中
对着手中的学术文献目不转睛
我从未踏进过一节语言学或者心理学的课堂
但是Steven Pinker, Steven Krashen, Paul Nation, Willem Nagy, Frank Smith, Paul Bloom, Lom Kato
这些大师学者们此刻就在我的暗头
在书页和屏幕上
他们的知识宅底24小时对我开放
只要我扣门
他们就会不厌其烦地教会我语言和万物的奥秘
那天我欣喜若狂
因为我发现自己从未离开过那个阅读乐园
但这一切全都开始于八年前
那辆颠簸嘈杂的火车上一本27块钱的二手小说
十九世纪末的两位语言学家Tussan and Langenscheid说
我们或许还可以加上
这是小说家Steven King
在他的写作回忆录中赠予读者们的许可
现在让我把它转赠给你
并请记住这条路上你并非孤身一人
因为今天我也在阅读
或许我也才学会了一个单词
发挥自己的创造力好吗
同时如果说Dr. Lamkato
在90年前学外语的时候
头疼于无处学习发音
发挥自己的创造力好吗
同时如果说Dr. Lamkato
还是挺难的我觉得这个问题
就每一个人再有经验的人
他也会一直
So you cannot lose hope in yourself
发挥自己的创造力好吗
同时如果说Dr. Lamkato
你不想说